dramatische szenen aus der ukrainischen
stadt erfordert die stadt ist zurzeit
von putins armee besetzt in den sozialen
medien und über ein großes international
renommiertes mediennetzwerk werden diese
bilder verbreitet am vormittag sollen
sich in der stadt an der linie per
zahlreiche einwohner vor dem
gemeindezentrum für eine pro ukrainische
kundgebung getroffen haben russische
truppen sollen die menschengruppen
umstellt haben dann wird es hektisch und
unübersichtlich explosionen sind zu
hören schüsse die menge zerstreut sich
der protest gegen die russischen
soldaten wird hier zerschlagen so hat es
den anschein
[Musik]
informationen über verletzte oder gar
tote gibt es aktuell nicht nach oder ist
ein strategisch wichtiger ort hier
befindet sich europas leistungsstärkstes
kernkraftwerks borussia
die stadt liegt rund 150 kilometer
luftlinie nordwestlich von der hart
umkämpften stadt mariupol seit dem 4
märz soll die putin armee die stadt
versetzt haben